[Music]
photograph 2,000 feet deep in the
Pacific Ocean off the California coast
the macro pinna micro stoma known as the
barreleye fish is small and dark with
large fins a tiny mouth an unusual
barrel eyes under a transparent dome the
two green spheres in the video are the
lenses of its tubular eyes the eyes are
enclosed within the transparent shield
sort of like the glass canopy of a jet
fighter above the mouth the two dark
capsules that appear to be eyes actually
contain the fishes olfactory organs or
the equivalent of nostrils
typically the barreleye sits quietly in
the water using its big fins for
stability while it scans the water above
for food when its spots food it can
rotate its eyes to look forward to
include its mouth in the field of view
scientists speculate that the barreleye
steals food from siphonophores elongated
jellies with tentacles that capture prey
that swims into them they believe the
barreleye swims into the tentacles and
steals the food from the siphonophore
the shield over its eyes protects them
from the stinging cells of the
siphonophores tentacles the barreleye
can also rotate its eyes to avoid
predators or avoid being captured by
scientists
the fish discovered alive by the
Monterey Bay Aquarium Research Institute
is the first specimen of its kind to be
found with its soft transparent dome
intact it had been known since 1939 but
only from mangled specimens dragged to
the surface by Nets
[Music]